[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
you
I joined where the [ __ ] you've been I've
been busy [ __ ] trying to put two
and two together and saying yeah put the
numbers together it's not all about fun
and [ __ ] games don't get me wrong I'm
still smoking dope before I removed like
a [ __ ] savage you understand me
Wednesday August 24th at law has been
canceled my deepest [ __ ]
apologies got nothing to do it uncle
Joey I'm saying I was just a cornerstone
in the [ __ ] corner and nobody
listened to me you know how it goes it's
a story of my [ __ ] life but I don't
give a [ __ ] I get up every morning I
grab my balls and I salute the [ __ ]
Flag and I'm telling me I'm ready for
you back suckers Joe what's with the
chitty-chat was [ __ ] the end on his
[ __ ] go grim Lagoon I went to see the
Russians before I picked up a little
pacified just to hold me over to the car
[ __ ] drying a 94 degree by tonight by
the time the podcast like that we don't
be [ __ ] [ __ ] there are film that will
prove whatever the [ __ ] they say in
French I don't wanna talk French
but sometimes you gotta improvise
younam's am the [ __ ] you're walking
in the room like you have the biggest
dick in the room in and you gotta
mention dick [ __ ] they don't know they
know [ __ ] it
guerilla glue you know I'm saying this
is how we [ __ ] do it
this is the [ __ ] they gave [ __ ] Jesus
when they woke them up in the cave and
said listen it's okay we healed up the
stitches you're gonna make a comeback
[ __ ]
I got introduced to just to get meet up
but every day I lose a little centimeter
of my fat [ __ ] ass and my fat [ __ ]
stomach and my heart's prompted and
understand me I do a little protein and
little seafood for lunch and that's it
and that's that the fungi nail is alive
and [ __ ] taken he's doing what he's
gathered opens
there's not fungi Malins fungi nel blu
anyway that said that was going on the
Churchill what's happening now tonight
eight [ __ ] o'clock what do I
got Thursday got the comedy store at
11:00 Friday night oh that's sad there
and I'll do some [ __ ] Sunday at the
store and the [ __ ] moon it's oh it's
all coming together for October
[ __ ] 15th and Rosemont Chicago
I'm gonna [ __ ] rip that [ __ ] joint
off
you guys know me if you know me you know
what I went through on my [ __ ] life
and I'm getting the opportunity of the
[ __ ] lifetime I'm gonna be more
prepared in [ __ ] Conor McGregor
that's the [ __ ] right there you
gotta be prepared like that if you not
prepared like that [ __ ] ain't gonna
[ __ ] go down I'm saying that's all I
got the same
as you know I'm [ __ ] spelling I've
been hit this [ __ ] since 7:35
a.m.
like working for this guy I'd love to
crack that I plopped another guy with
the jujitsu I sweat out the THC that I
had at my system and now the adrenals
are ready for more [ __ ] THC
understand yeah I don't know what we eat
tonight we got a bunch of [ __ ] down
there we got cheaper Jews we got [ __ ]
the stars a debt tonight's gonna be a
collaboration of different [ __ ] th
seas and different [ __ ] syndromes and
[ __ ]
before that thing is on him no syndrome
[ __ ] it means you I am natural guys you
got the wrong guy
and hurt the mat I read some books from
time to time unlike my business I'm Sam
let's finish off this gorilla go I got
the last two bowls of that [ __ ]
roving towelettes down there oh jesus
before I spill my tea
if you're bald if you sniff this [ __ ]
Lucho pop out of your [ __ ] skull
you're like Joey you should have have
your own [ __ ] bulb or whatever
try to put the pieces together every
[ __ ] thing oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we're
going deep into the THC murky waters the
[ __ ] underworld you know what I'm just
gonna fill this up pack it in and really
[ __ ] kill the [ __ ] diaphragm
that's that though something for the
spirits you don't say me I let him know
you're the [ __ ] house [ __ ]
I move myself up with that one that's
how we do it here we go all day they
understand you wanna rock
you wanna rock with uncle Joey this
night the smartest [ __ ] I don't
know all the words I'm no [ __ ] it
thesaurus I knew that one cuz I shop the
5th thesaurus one time for a year sat
there I don't know what the [ __ ] it was
but I learned the word thesaurus anyway
if you don't know now you're not stone
to the [ __ ] diesels I love that you
guys join me for this little have to
don't take time today way that we do
this technician what [ __ ] country can
we do this type of [ __ ] up nowhere right
here
meanwhile some Chinese guy probably read
the [ __ ] periscope little sneaky
[ __ ]
anyway I love you [ __ ] were all
my heart
you guys know without you have a gots
but anyway I keep [ __ ] taking like a
bomb [ __ ] tonight 8:00 p.m. the
Churchill what's happening now be there
will [ __ ] go shoot yourself and poor
ranch dressing on yourself [ __ ]
and end it
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight
I'm hearing things
I love you kind of suck to stay black
for you if their mom in lobbying the
hallway sorry